Oracle one is adapted a swift warning
from Nancy Pelosi to her fellow
Democrats do not share this solemn rare
moment in American history
Donald Trump has become only the third
u.s. president to be impeached every
president's nightmare has already become
his battle cry I think we have a vote
coming in so we got every single
Republican voted for us whoa
[Applause]
there's no crime right there's no crime
I'm the first person that ever getting
beats in this real crime I like I feel
guilty you know they call it impeachment
like it's a pitchman life the Democrats
got what they wanted but were careful
not to appear too triumphant December
18th a great day to the Constitution of
the United States a sad one for America
that the president's reckless activities
necessitated us are having to introduce
articles of impeachment this has been a
tale of two impeachments warned of sober
urgent necessity when President Trump
conditioned military aid on a personal
favor he harmed America's national
security and when he demanded that a
foreign government target his domestic
political rival he took steps to corrupt
our next election to the founders these
offenses clearly mérida removal from
office the other is a story of an
unfounded and unfair process I see
coming off a president who will put his
head down even through this sham
impeachment and he will do his job he
will put the American people first
he will tell them that I care about you
he will still put the economy first and
he will make sure this country stands
strong Americans are now absorbing this
moment but most people had made their
minds up before the process began
Trump's haters have only had their worst
fears confirmed his supporters are
echoing his cries of a witch-hunt it's
that rare breed now of undecided
independent voters who are crucial will
they vote for an impeached president
Americans have witnessed a pitched
battle Donald Trump will continue the
fight now it's on to the Senate widely
regarded as the place impeachment goes
to die
the Democrats next challenge will be an
acquitted emboldened Trump intent on
another four years as commander-in-chief
Amanda Walker Sky News Washington